ah forget about dragons westeros because
the biggest threat headed your way
is me
hello internet welcome to film theory
where
just like a lannister always pays his
debts a matpat
always delivers his theories in the
crazy ever-changing world of game of
thrones
at least there are a few things you can
always count on winter is always coming
the targaryens always have great hair
and no one likes dorne seriously
no one likes dorne but if there's one
thing i've learned about this series
it's that you can't actually rely on
anything
george r.r martin's love of throwing
fantasy tropes out the window like a
young bran stark means that there is no
assumption that you can count on which
is why i'm so excited about this episode
as i finally get to target the family
that we all think we know
the targaryens in particular i've had my
eye on the mad king for a long time now
and today we're gonna talk about just
how mad he is
quick warning though a light sprinkling
of spoilers ahead so i pray to the old
gods that you're all caught up now
season six of the series was the first
time ever we've gotten a look at the
most famous targaryen ancestor aerys ii
the mad king himself and what a looker
he is
now there are all kinds of theories
going around about the mad king and
there are plenty of upcoming film
theories about the fella but today i'm
less interested in history and more
interested in whether
history is going to repeat itself
because for as excited as we all are for
westeros to get wrecked by danny and her
armies
dothraki hordes ships and dragons the
biggest twist in her story may yet be
coming and sadly nothing
sir friend zone does will be able to
stop it nope
danny may have a ticking bomb inside of
her
remember the most famous family genes in
the whole series
the targaryens i.e the genes that let
you walk through
fire talk to dragons and make sure you
always look like a pantene pro-v
model also tend to lead to rulers who
are violent deranged and
just weird according to game of thrones
canon ares ii was perfectly
sane in his 20s showing no signs that he
had gotten the insane targaryen genes
only to develop his homicidal crazies a
little bit later in life
after becoming king so is it just a
matter of time for daenerys as well
can science help us predict whether dany
is destined to follow in her father's
footsteps
i intend to find out to figure it out we
need to take a look at the targaryen
family tree
and boy is it a doozy now on this show i
usually try to stick to the lore from
the tv show only since at this point the
two have taken
different story arcs for this one we
needed to call out the big guns to piece
together daenerys genetic situation
and fully understand exactly what she's
inheriting which means the lesson of
today's episode is the wonderful world
of
inbreeding and when i say wonderful i
mean pretty weird
like research for this episode was very
uncomfortable but to diagnose her
likelihood of becoming the mad queen of
westeros we need to understand what
happens when related individuals do the
horizontal mambo
and genetically why so many societies
have rules against marrying into your
own family
other than the obvious creep factor
which again
is pretty darn high hashtag love is love
most of the time now before darwin and
genetics people did know that inbreeding
produced kids that had physical and
mental disabilities who tended to die
younger or
frankly didn't survive at all but the
reasons behind that have to do with
genetic science that came out in the
1800s specifically
recessive genes and genetic mutations
and basically how many are lurking under
the surface of our own genes
every day so if you didn't sleep through
seventh grade science hopefully you know
that every person in the world has two
copies of all their genes
one you inherit from your mom and the
other from your dad
in textbooks you see them sitting
together in these cute little pairs
all nice and getting along but the story
in your cells
is a whole lot different one of the
biggest reasons we have two copies of
jeans from two parents
is to cover up mutations and alternate
forms of genes in the genome and what mr
foster didn't tell me in seventh grade
science is that there are actually
tons of these genetic mistakes inside
all of us
so if gene one from your dad doesn't
quite have its act together the one on
the allele you got from your mom
can cover its tracks making sure that
you still produce everything that you
need
like blood cells and bones and kylie
jenner duck lips
sometimes the traits these genes are for
are just unimportant
like handedness or the ability to taste
certain bitter chemicals but then
there are other genes that you
definitely want to have a backup for
diseases like sickle cell anemia and
cystic fibrosis are two of the most
famous autosomal recessive diseases but
there are
literally hundreds more most of which
you don't really hear too much about
because they're pretty darn rare and the
reason they're rare is that most people
have a backup set of genes that help
them minimize the effects of these
disorders
notice though that i said most if you
don't have a backup set of jeans then
boy howdy you're in trouble
which brings us to danny and her family
history
of inbreeding inbreeding is actually
really complicated and what we're
talking about here
just scratches the surface studying
inbreeding is basically about how many
genes get recycled directly from
generation to generation
to do that population specialists use
what's known as the coefficient of
inbreeding it's like they make
coefficients for literally anything
these days
coefficient of when winter is coming
coefficient of extraneous boob
shots and game of thrones but a
coefficient of inbreeding measures how
many identical copies of a gene they
have because it came from the same
ancestor in other words it helps us
understand how much of daenerys dna is
the exact same as the mad king's because
it came directly from him
and his inbreeding ancestors this in
turn ought to give us a good indication
of whether we can expect daenerys to
follow in the footsteps
of his let's just say less than sane
ruling practices
now the equation for calculating the
inbreeding coefficient for any person
is so right
yeah i'm going to assume that you don't
want me to walk through every variable
on that one so instead let's use the
power of google to see what the
inbreeding coefficient would be for the
children of
two siblings using google and some weird
research into dairy cow breeding we can
find that the sibling pairings will
result in
offspring that share 50 of their genes
with their grandparents and have an
inbreeding coefficient
of 25 meaning that they have a 25
chance of being affected by those nasty
recessive gene diseases we talked about
and the numbers are all well and good
but to put it in perspective let's look
at a real world example first
king tutankhamun known by his peeps as
king tut is one of the most famous cases
of real world
inbreeding since his parents were
actually brother and sister he's
portrayed in egyptian mythology as this
powerful sun god but in reality he was
really tiny
likely sick his whole life had a
congenital club foot couldn't produce
any living children and died at age
19. plus he's the only child from his
parents that we know who actually
survived so
what happened here well his grandparents
weren't
inbred so first off a big pat on the
back to those guys for
finding love in all the right places
his parents though not so much they were
siblings meaning that they already
share 50 of the same dna just by being
closely related now they would have been
fine if they had gone on to have kids
with other people but they decided to
keep it all in the family
meaning that any kid they had would be
inbred like
really in bread when they had king tut
it meant that he had a 25
inbreeding coefficient because he's the
product of two siblings versus say
a zero percent coefficient if his
parents weren't actually related it also
means that he shares 50
of his genes with his grandparents where
he normally would only share 25
of his genes with them under normal
circumstances as a result his odds of
getting any one of those rare genetic
diseases
is now as high as one in four and across
so many possible disorders chances are
you're going to end up with at least a
few of the biggies and that's the thing
about the genetics of
inbreeding it's all about percent
chances and playing the odds
kind of like vegas but with your genes
sure you can definitely get lucky every
once in a while
if say having a club foot and dying by
19 is considered
lucky but statistically speaking serious
genetic mutations become common as soon
as you get to a coefficient of
inbreeding that's 10
or higher so what does this mean for
daenerys
well as you go through more and more
generations of inbreeding the problems
get worse
and worse really fast and say what you
will about the targaryens but they were
prolific inbreeders a little examination
of that massive family tree shows that
you can go back
19 generations from daenerys and 12 of
them
have sibling sibling inbreeding involved
talk about your brotherly love
actually don't talk about that it's
gross then again i'm still talking about
it so
welcome to film theory ladies and
gentlemen so okay let's give her the
absolute biggest
benefit of the doubt and only go back
three generations to the last time that
there was
any any sort of outbreathing in the
targaryen line aegon the unlikely
unlikely to survive based on the
family's incestuous history that is
baduching aegon the unlikely managed to
marry black betha
a real live non-targaryan oh but okay
sure now it's a race thing seriously
though black beth is just her name now
aegon unlikely also comes from
inbreeding but by marrying betha and
outcrossing he effectively resets the
targaryen inbreeding coefficient to zero
according to the lore aegon didn't
believe in inbreeding but two of his
kids
fell in love and got married bringing
their kids including mad king
aerys ii up to that 25 inbreeding
coefficient
as a result it would be incredibly
unlikely that either ares or his sister
would live long enough to grow up and
they would almost
certainly have no chance of having
viable kids an issue known as
inbreeding depression no that's not the
feeling you get when your sister starts
having feelings for your first cousin
that's actually when most populations
become sterile after one to two
generations of close inbreeding because
their dna is simply too
damaged to even create a baby but most
importantly to us
the risk of aries having alzheimer's and
dementia diseases that specifically show
up
later in life happen at much higher
rates in inbred populations
more recessive genes mean more genes
associated with dimension alzheimer's
get turned on
leading to the disease showing up more
often and more severely
it also shows up earlier in life because
inbreeding causes the body to
literally age faster since its dna is
too fragile and literally more likely
just to break apart
if you need a real life example just
look at maria of portugal in the 1700s
whose life has some pretty bizarre
similarities to our favorite mad king
the product of royal inbreeding she
started off as a strong decisive ruler
early in life
until she started having delirious
episodes and developing dementia her
condition got worse after the death of
her husband and son and she lived the
rest of her life in her own mind
those around her reported constantly
hearing her paranoid shrieking and
screaming as she was going mad her
kingdom was taken over and the whole
portuguese royal family at the time was
forced to flee across the ocean to
brazil
in 1801. historically she's been
referred to
as the mad queen so what are daenerys's
odds of sharing the same fate as her
father and maria of portugal how do i
put this lightly
really really freaking high preposterous
high daenerys has 75 of her genes in
common with viserys and her father aries
ii
75 that means that she's incredibly
likely to share the exact same fate as
him when we hear tyrion tell her that
she's starting to sound a lot like her
father you once told me you knew what
your father was
did you know his plans for king's
landing when the lannister armies were
at his gates
this is entirely different talking about
destroying cities
it's not entirely different it's because
she literally
is her father three-fourths of her is
her father
physically mentally genetically her fate
is pretty well sealed man brings new
meaning to the idea of
daddy's little girl now if you carry
this out to its logical conclusion it
also has some serious implications for
her position as queen
the reason her first son died before he
was born we think it was magic
we assume it was magic but the much more
likely explanation is that she's too
inbred to produce a living heir based on
genetics it's practically impossible for
her to have a living offspring and
forget about marrying her even if she
makes it back to westeros and reclaims
the iron throne for her family
statistically it's almost impossible
that she could extend her own family
tree
there is literally no point in her
becoming queen because there's so little
chance that there will be anyone there
to take it on
after her well i guess there's always
cersei but if all this seems a bit
extreme
if applying science to game of thrones
seems a bit absurd you don't have to
take my word for it instead
take george r.r martin's word in the
epilogue of a dance with dragons
mace tyrell declares that daenerys is
quote
as mad as her father just a throwaway
line
or foreshadowing at what's to come once
daenerys takes over westeros
we'll have to wait and see until then
though remember
it's just a theory a film
theory and cut
well time to embarrass myself if you go
way back to the earliest videos on the
game theorist channel then you'll see
that i used to do myself a bit of
singing back in the day
is that a wish i was so cute and young
then well in honor of this game of
thrones theory i partnered up with one
of the best musicians on youtube
a man by the name of peter hollins and
got to work out with him as bran stark
in his rendition of the game of thrones
theme song
so please do me a favor and click here
to rock out with me to one of the
catchiest opening theme songs to a tv
show
ever he got me this really awesome
costume and everything i
felt so legit fair warning you'll have
it caught in your head the rest of the
afternoon or if you'd like another game
of thrones theory check out this one
with my prediction on how sir jorah will
be the hero
of westeros seriously the guy's still
kicking around he has a big role to play
in the events next season
and for all you dhmis fans don't worry
just need a little bit more time in the
edit that one's coming out
next week for all you doctor who fans
meanwhile
you might be waiting just a little bit
longer so pass the time by listening to
the game of thrones theme song over and
over again
click there
foreign